why did the smartphone go to jail
because it was charged with battery
almost all smartphones that we come
across are rectangular in shape why why
aren't they shaped in the form of
triangles circles or maybe squares let's
find out first let's talk about the
uniqueness of a rectangle if we compare
the area of a rectangle with the areas
of a triangle a circle or a square of
similar dimensions we see that the area
of a rectangle is the greatest of all so
its maximum area the only reason imagine
reading text on a circular device do you
notice the empty spaces here the area
isn't used efficiently don't you think
the same goes for a triangle as well yes
so we can safely eliminate these two
shapes now you may argue what's wrong
with a square we can't definitely use
its area efficiently right that gets us
to an important point let's hold both
the smartphone's in the shape of a
square and a rectangle now we increase
the lengths of both the devices such
that they have the same height what do
you see here don't you think it will be
more difficult to hold this one with one
hand relative to this one
of course so handling a rectangular
device is easier wait there's more while
reading the text
we prefer lesser width as it's easier on
our eyes and while watching a video we
prefer a wider lens again the
rectangular shape helps us here so
rectangle can be considered as the best
shape when it comes to smartphones great
now for something interesting
flip your smartphone and focus on the
camera region if you see carefully the
length of the camera is circular in
shape and the images we get on our
display are rectangular in shape what
exactly is happening here does the
circular lens directly capture
rectangular images or does it capture
circular images first which are
processed into rectangular images what
do you think this cue box is open for
you to explore do share your thoughts in
the comment section below and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
learn about awesome things happy
learning